dans le domaine du piratage cette fois
des milliers de français s'échangent
quotidiennement par le biais d'internet
des disques des films des jeux vidéo ils
sont dans l'illégalité
mais pour le moment le risque de
sanctions ne fait pas vraiment peur aux
internautes un coup de fil elle vient
d'être lancée il vise particulièrement
ceux qui sont les premiers à mettre un
film en ligne beaucoup moins ceux qui
les copies c'est l'un des réseaux les
plus importants démantelés en france
sophie rodier régis mater
opération gj team cela pourrait être le
nom d'un film policier mais c'est d'une
affaire bien réel qu'il s'agit des
milliers de dvd sévit 40 disques durs
autant d'unités centrales au total
quatorze mille films contrefaits
certains très récent diffusé
illégalement sur internet à l'origine de
ce trafic une équipe de 30 personnes
leur nom la gg tim hill récupérer les
films il est signé j'étais surtout les
liens ils voulaient être reconnues comme
étant l'équipe française qui diffusait
en premier les films nommé de la
meilleure qualité possible
l'envié d'être reconnue plus que l'appât
du gain car la gg team ne gagnait pas
d'argent dans cette affaire mais pour
l'association de lutte contre la
piraterie audiovisuelle qui portent
systématiquement plein cela ne change
rien qu'ils gagnent de l'argent ou pas
le fait de mettre à disposition des
oeuvres sans autorisation des ayants
droit
est une infraction pénale en plus il
porte atteinte directement et portent un
préjudice aux ayants droit en permettant
l'accès à des oeuvres qui n'ont pas se
trouver sur internet cinq ans de prison
cinq cent mille euros damende les
pirates savent ce qu'ils encourent c'est
le cas de ce jeune homme qui a déjà
téléchargé illégalement 700 films on
peut voir que la haine et hajar plein
j'en ai également dans tout le bureau
tous les tiroirs en sont pleins elle des
petits boîtiers des pochettes pratique
pour ranger plusieurs c'est la peur
d'être pris
non dans la mesure où on fait attention
et on fait ça dans un cadre privé
vraiment pour une passion celle des
films la détente personnel et qu'on n'en
fait pas un commerce je vois c'est
illégal mais à moi à mes yeux n'en à mes
yeux je continuerai n'y a pas de
problème
pour décourager les irréductibles
l'industrie du cinéma mis sur une
nouvelle arme l'humour
le message pas d'argent pas de cinéma
plus de six ans après